you moved here the United States from
Hong Kong
who's that right yeah did you know even
as a kid
Mike you wanted your career to be in
show business was that a dream as a
child I had no idea I don't think that
was like a possibility growing up my dad
always said like pursuing your dreams
how you become homeless yeah that's nice
to have that stitched on a pillow yeah
yeah exactly
but that when I came here like it was I
wanted that independence of finding my
own way I like I grew up listening it
like 50 cent like that was like my [ __ ]
yeah like yeah she unit Conan I don't
know if you know but I do know I do now
yeah I couldn't hear distinctly but now
I know g-unit yeah so that was my like
my stuff growing up but then I went to
college and I got an economics degree
because that was the easiest degree that
can still applies your Asian parents
yeah and then after that I really I
didn't know what to do so I had three
jobs I was a used car salesman during
the day and then I worked at a comedy
club at a door mm-hmm
and then at night after the comedy club
shift I worked as a strip club DJ now
I'm gonna ask you to explain in detail
one of those jobs you can guess which
one but I'm fascinated by being a strip
club DJ what is that like I think
growing up watching like the 50 cent
Ludacris music videos like as a kid like
this is a dream to work in a strip club
you know but really it's not
[Laughter]
but he was a dancer and that's the yeah
so so so what you you you work there and
what was like what was your routine at
the strip club you just you just it was
like high-pressure sales it was really
the perfect job for me because I
combined the salesmanship that I learned
in the used-car lot with the microphone
skills that I got doing stand-up and I
became like a really cool strip club lap
dance salesman according to the owner
sales went up 44% the first week I was
there Wow
I don't know him so well how would you
sell a lap dance then is it is there
something like maybe strip club P music
we can play Jimmy is there alright
ladies gentlemen one more time for the
beautiful but line coming off the stage
all right for the next ten minutes
two-for-one lap dance is coming off
right now the gentleman and a purple tie
I've seen you here before
yeah I won't everybody in the VIP right
now for the next time it's two-for-one
lap dance inside you can get to lap
dances for the price of one with your
favorite girl I love a bargain whoa oh
you can get one lap dance with two of
your favorite girls right here in
fantasy show oh gosh
why don't I get what I'll do both to
with one girl and then to with the other
Oh Ethan I can do all the negotiations
you want in the VIP
so Andy you did seem like a guy who was
in town for a convention sure and had
never been to a strip club before well
okay I'll do both I just heard there was
a buffet legs and eggs halen legs you
huh that's a real thing
you